the top business stories live from the
Sky News City Studio
UK economy contracts in May but by less
than expected
profiting from a changing world the CEO
of Wood Group on how it's leading the
transition to Green energy
and high-end expectations retailer
watches of Switzerland defies the Gloom
with record results
[Music]
good morning this is business live with
Ian King the UK economy shrank by less
than expected in May it emerged this
morning UK GDP was always expected to
contract during the month due to the
extra bank holiday for the king's
coronation but a contraction of 0.1
percent was better than the 0.3 percent
that had been anticipated the office for
National statistics said all parts of
the economy contracted during the month
with the exception of the services
sector which merely stagnated the ons
said there had been benefits to
businesses in the Arts entertainment and
Recreation sectors as a result of the
coronation but warned manufacturing
output had taken a hit from the extra
bank holiday the UK economy is now
estimated to be 0.2 percent bigger than
it was in February 2020 going into the
pandemic
separately the government's fiscal
Watchdog has this morning warned that
the UK's debt is at risk of rising to
three times the country's GDP by the
2070s the office for Budget
responsibility said the 2020s were
turning out to be a very risky era for
the public finances warning that as the
baby boomer cohort retires and pushes up
the cost of the triple lock staked
pension spending is expected to be 23
billion pounds higher in 2027-28 than at
the start of the decade it also warns
that rising take-up of electric vehicles
is expected to cost 13 billion pounds a
year in foregone fuel Duty by 2030.
now while many parts of the economy face
headwinds there are plenty of businesses
enjoying robust demand one such as John
Wood Group the global Consulting and
Engineering business the company which
employs more than 35 000 people around
the world including four and a half
thousand in Aberdeen this morning
reported sales to 2.9 billion US dollars
for the first six months of the year up
15 on the same period in 2022 we're
joining me now is Ken Gilmartin the Wood
Group CEO Ken very good to see you this
morning I mean you're enjoying growth in
all parts of the business but
particularly in Project work what's
behind that
yeah Ian listen thanks for having me as
well delighted to be on you know what
we're seeing in our projects group
growth is is consistent across the
entire Globe so our end markets energy
security energy transition chemicals
Life Sciences as well as mineral
processing what we're seeing is clients
investing money uh we're seeing clients
investing money across all of the
geographies that we serve and I think
you know for us as wood we're in those
right markets we're there the right way
and we're there at the right time
obviously our viewers with older longer
memories will remember you primarily
it's an oil field services business but
you've clearly Diversified over the
years how long before oil field services
is the sort of smaller part of what you
do
yeah I mean I think Oilfield Services is
part of that energy security that's you
know fundamental and a foundational
piece of where we are as a group you
know we've embarked on a three-year
strategic cycle in and as we move
through that strategic cycle energy
security energy transition there's still
going to be big parts of that but as we
go through that three years energy
transition is going to become more
important and then you look into the
materials business that we have so we
have mineral processing we've got Life
Sciences as I said originally we've got
chemicals as well and as we go through
those years they're going to continue to
grow as well so our portfolio is
Diversified but it's under bin by the 36
000 people that we have that are the
world-class subject matter experts that
we're really proud of
now the Biden Administration is
incentivizing investment in green energy
to the tune of 369 billion dollars is
that changing the way you're deploying
Capital around the world
I mean I think it's been absolutely an
accelerator and I think it's definitely
in that energy transition space where
you know we have that leading subject
matter expertise that has become that
accelerator for growth as well and you
know we've got over 10 000 people in
North America and a lot of those are
really really excited about that
opportunity that brings because it does
does facilitate that acceleration that
we have where we're really good is where
we can join the dots from a global
standpoint and that means bringing the
best the brightest resources the subject
matter expertise that we have anywhere
in the globe to Bear irrespective of
where the capital has been deployed and
that's that's what we're good at that's
our differentiator and that's we're
going to continue to do
the closer to home there's obviously
been a lot of unhappiness in the UK oil
and gas industry about windfall taxes
has the UK government done the right
thing in your view in reigning those in
yeah I'm going to think look tax policy
is probably something to have a
conversation with with the politicians I
think for me and what we're looking at
is you got to make sure however that
there is an absolute focus on investment
you know the UK needs critical
infrastructure the UK needs to continue
to invest and as that journey to Net
Zero continues to go that energy
transition is going to going to take
pace and you need to continue to invest
in order to do that so that would be my
that would be my piece on windfall tax
yes or no but make sure that we're
continuing to invest where we need to
now your head count Rose during the
first half you're taking on more people
it's a skill set that you're looking for
different from how it used to be
I think it's continued to evolve over
the years I think we're still very
highly dominated by engineer scientists
what we're seeing more is data data
analytics starting to become more
prevalent in the stuff that we're doing
particular years are on that journey to
Ai and some generative AI in the design
of what we're doing so yeah skill set
continues to evolve but that ability to
have people that critically think and
can solve what are the world's most
critical challenges that we're facing at
the moment and still something that
we're always passionate about and making
sure that we get the brightest and the
best
and I mean I've got to ask you this Ken
obviously during the first half of the
year you had no fewer than five takeover
approaches from uh Apollo how much of a
distraction was that on on management
time
yeah I mean I think at the top levels of
the organization certainly it was it was
a distraction but I think the important
thing for us as a company was we
embarked on a new strategy in November
last year Ian and I think irrespective
of the ownership we knew that the
strategy that you have is a strategy
that's going that we're going to execute
that we're going to grow we're going to
win uh I think the results that we
showed today showed that the strategy is
continuing to work that we are in those
right markets in the right way at the
right time so I think the distraction
yes for management before the for the 36
000 people that we have in the
organization we've built significant
momentum in the first half and that's by
being able to stay focused on the
strategy that we've unveiled
Ken gotta leave it there terrific to
talk to you this morning thanks very
much indeed for joining me
thank you again take care
a bit of uh breaking news that we can
bring you uh the BBC director General
Tim Davey is to be questioned in
Parliament following the Hugh Edwards
Scandal the BBC director General the
acting chairwoman Dane Elaine cloth
Stevens and the policy director of the
BBC Claire Sumner have been called to
appear before the house of laws
Communications committee next week
now I made all the talk about the need
for the UK to build gigafactories to
service the electric vehicle sector it's
worth remembering there are alternatives
to lithium-ion batteries chiefly
solid-state batteries or specializing in
the latter is ilica Technologies a
spin-off of the University of
southampton's chemistry Department today
it reported turnover of 702 000 pounds
for the year to the end of April up 42
on the previous year but its pre-tact
losses widened by 11 to 8.9 million
pounds as it ramped up spending well
joining me now is gray and Purdy he's
chief executive of ilica Graham good to
see you this morning I mean first of all
very simple question for those who are
on to know about these things what's the
chief difference between Lithium-ion
batteries and solid state batteries
morning Ian many thanks for the uh
invitation to your news this morning
um so the the principal difference is
that in a solid state battery the liquid
electrolyte and polymer separator which
are put between the two electrodes in
the cell are replaced by a lithium ion
conducting but electrically insulating
ceramic which allows the battery to
charge and discharge and gives it a very
compact design
and what are the advantages of solid
status you see them
principal advantages are that you get a
higher energy density uh of the cell and
what that means actually is that when
you put these cells together to form a
battery pack it gives the consumer a
longer driving range for the vehicle so
it overcomes some of that range anxiety
second Advantage is that normal
Lithium-ion batteries are inflammable
are flammable and when you replace that
liquid electrolyte with a ceramic you
turn the battery into a much safer
device and therefore the amount of
engineering that you need to put into
the battery pack once it's in the
vehicle is reduced and therefore the
cost and bulk of the battery pack is
minimized well we might get onto EVS in
a moment but it means probably the big
Landmark for you during the first half
was the M50 which is your smallest solid
state battery you've started delivering
those I gather
that's right we've got two product lines
on the one hand we've got our stereax
batteries which are Miniature batteries
uh designed specially for miniature
medical implants
um and we've started delivering them
from our UK facility and then on the
other hand we've got our large formats
Goliath cells which are designed for EVS
so uh the technical maturity of our
steriac cells has increased to the point
where we've been able to start shipments
to customers a gather the stereax is
less than a millimeter thick I mean that
that's absolutely extraordinary
yeah
um you know we've designed these cells
to be the the minimum size possible uh
you can imagine if you're unlucky enough
to need a miniature medical implant then
actually you want cells that are uh
absolutely thin and and Tiny uh and uh
need the the minimum surgical
intervention as well as being
intrinsically safe you know there's no
toxic liquid electrolytes that can leak
out of these steriac cells and that
combined with their long life means that
the implants are in demand
and where are these being manufactured
Graeme
so at the moment uh they're being
manufactured at our facility uh here in
the UK just outside of Southampton uh we
have a small facility that we built over
the last couple of years
we've just entered into a scale-up tech
transfer deal with surtec which is a
large U.S headquartered company that
specializes in medical devices we're at
mou stage with them so memorandum of
understanding and we're finalizing the
contracts uh to the point where we can
carry out that Tech transfer in the
second half of the year with a view to
ramping production and selling to what
are primarily uh U.S centered
oems uh into their medical devices
Grandma wanted to ask you about the
Goliath but I'm a flavor out of time so
we'll have to do that another day I'm
afraid thanks for joining me today all
right thank you
[Music]
well the parent has continued to grind
higher against the US Dollar on the
foreign exchange markets following
yesterday's benign U.S inflation data
Sterling this morning hit its highest
level against the Greenback since the
21st of April last year
currently ahead by half of one percent
touching 1.31 the oil price is also
ticking up on the back of the weaker
dollar Valor Brent crude will currently
set you back 80. 33 cents about that's
up for nearly a third of one percent
that's an 11 week high that Brent crude
is currently trading at on the equity
markets wall Street's gains last night
were followed by a solid session
overnight in the Asia Pacific region
during which the nickname Tokyo enjoyed
its best gain in a fortnight in Europe
stocks are also in positive territory
right now again lifted by hopes the
Federal Reserve May soon be done with
raising U.S interest rates talking
points this morning include the Swiss
watchmaker Swatch it shares ahead by six
and a half percent in Zurich on better
than expected results well here in
London the ftse 100 is also in positive
territory up a third of one percent
right now the mining heavyweights are
lending support there among the fallers
well the leading footsie Faller is the
house Builder Barrett developments uh
rather downbeat trading statement it put
out this morning the shares of three and
a quarter percent all of the other major
Blue Chip per house builders Taylor
wimpy persimmon and Barclay group are
down with that in sympathy as you can
see there outside the ftse curries is
ahead by one and a half percent that's
all news at the Spanish investor cobass
Asset Management has raised its stake
from eight to nine percent meanwhile
International distribution services had
had another one and a half percent and
that is after its role a male Arm
yesterday reached an agreement with the
unions who are joining me now is the
head of equity research at Rathbone
Investment Management sanjiv tumka Sanji
great to see I haven't seen you on the
program for a while
um this statement from Barrett
developments is a bit downbeat isn't it
um yeah it's tough times for the the
house builders at the moment you know
we've seen what's happened with mortgage
rates
um obviously the consumers Under
Pressure
um it's it's not a great time for
affordability
um but having said that I mean I think
if you step back
um the house builders have learned the
lessons from the previous down Cycles
they've got strong balance sheets you
know barretts has reported that net cash
position of more than a billion pounds
so I think that should give people
confidence that whatever the vagaries of
the near-term trading um that the um you
know the the company's you know well
placed in the long term and it actually
got the balance sheet to take advantage
of opportunities if they see land prices
fall of course I mean they said today
that they're going to build a fifth
fewer houses this year than they did in
the last Financial year I mean that has
a knock-on effect to brick makers I mean
I see for Terror and ibstock the two
quoted brick makers have been in the
doldrums lately and like why some of the
Builders Merchants presumably yes
absolutely it's that whole ecosystem
Beyond just the house builders that
multiplier effect but equally when
things do do take turn a corner and I'm
sure they they will before too long then
then you get that positive multiplier
but but clearly you know with interest
rates where they are now that's having
an impact on the real economy and the
house builders 100 domestic UK earnings
is one of the areas that's going to base
that yeah now another stock that caught
your eye again in the ftse 100 Experian
we don't talk about that on this program
very much what did you make and what
they had to say today
um I think
um experience a really really
interesting UK Global leader we have a
number of them I think sometimes people
are quite down beat on the UK economy
we've actually got a lot of really good
companies Experian you know a global
leader in data services it started from
quite humble Origins and credit bureaus
and it's developed that to become this
this you know very Diversified data
analytics company its data helps people
you know sort of uh originate loans
decide decide whether to give people
loans or not
um prevent fraud all sorts of things
which are more and more important than
our in our kind of data economy
um and that the information that they
have is a lot of its proprietary goes
back a long time that's very valuable
and they've done a great job of
commercializing that so A really
interesting kind of long-term uh success
story in the UK and their results you
know uh the q1 sales were up at five
percent on an organic underlying basis
which is pretty healthy given what we're
seeing in the overall economy at the
moment yeah and more broadly obviously
there's a lot of optimism following
those that U.S inflation data yesterday
is that misplaced at all do you feel and
it's so it's so hard to judge isn't it
people are constantly watching every
single opinion that any member of the
Federal Reserve board is saying about
the direction of interest rates I guess
you know the core inflation does seem to
be ameliorating you know point point at
point two percent month or month versus
expectations of 0.3 percent
um and it seems like especially if you
strip out things like a shelter costs so
accommodation and rents and things
actually the the call numbers are
looking a lot healthier still not where
the FED wants them to be but getting
closer so I think the Market's starting
to think well maybe there might be
another rate rise but after that maybe
maybe that's it I think the bigger
question is when does the FED start
cutting and um that's that's very hard
to tell and my personal view is it
doesn't happen very quickly right
subject there's loads more wanted to ask
you we're at a time of afraid thank you
thank you
still to come here on business live why
Watchers of Switzerland expect some
continuing growth despite the somewhat
difficult economic Outlook don't go away
[Music]
foreign
slight better
[Music]
Fly Emirates fly better
thank you
welcome back now one of the most robust
sectors in the global economy since the
end of the pandemic has been luxury
goods and that was underlined today by
record results from watches of
Switzerland the UK's biggest luxury
watch retailer reported a pre-tax profit
of 155 million pounds for the year to
the end of April up 26 on the previous
12 months with sales Rising by 25 to one
and a half billion pounds we can speak
now with the chief executive of watches
of Switzerland Brian Duffy Brian good to
see you again this morning
um big increase in sales how did that
how what was the mix there how much was
volume and how much was price
uh it was more uh price or more average
selling price than a volume which has
you know been typical for our growth
over uh several years
um I'm actually out of actual price
increases that implemented um buyers but
on recommendation by the brands but the
biggest single Factor has actually been
people trading up on the on average
selling prices people buying more gold
uh product uh less gold and steel less
steel
um so the volume contribution actually
that I could also the the smallest part
the biggest Single part of the people
tearing up and I'll be selling price and
the pricing impact gun and the whole
thing has been somewhere um around seven
percent last year
and where a price is going over the next
12 months
uh there are numbers in our guidance uh
the impact of pricing is around three
percent
um we never anticipate placing typically
it happens at the start of the calendar
year happens January February we never
anticipated so we'll see what comes but
there's nothing in our guidance for that
um so um yeah three percent as they
carry forward or the pricing that
happened last year
now you open during the year 27
showrooms and boutiques what's going to
be informing the policy on openings this
year
we carry on you know we get a great
return on Capital you'll have seen a
return on the capital employed at 27.9
percent
um we get our payback uh less than three
years but on Capital and on working
capital so if it has been our entire
um strategy through this whole period of
transformation we've been doing over the
last 10 years has been really to invest
invest in big beautiful stores and
client service and marketing our
returning Capital has always been good
we'd spend more if we could
um Mr might have just you know finding
the right opportunities getting the
right level of brand support uh but we
continually increase our capex which is
uh which is driving our sales and profit
growth and what's interesting is that
you're going into a lot of new European
markets for the first time
yes we are with a great success in the
U.S you know the U.S is you know now 42
of our business uh we went there five
years ago all of that has come in uh the
last five years so it's been a great
success actually beyond our expectations
to be honest and when we uh decided to
go to the U.S it was on the basis of us
uh examining the market and seeing that
on a per capita basis it was
significantly less than the than the the
UK uh where obviously we've been present
for a for for many many decades uh and
we've analyzed the situation as uh
underdeveloped because of a lack of
investment in retail and I think that's
proven to be true with the what we and
the others have done in the US so we've
done the same analysis in the Europe
sales per capita uh it leads us to
conclude almost every Market in Europe
is one in which our proposition would uh
would bring success
um we are we started in in the nordics
um who were
particularly underdeveloped as a as
we've seen we've just recently opened
our first store in Germany we're a bit
of a concentration on Northern Europe
but uh so far so good the customer
clients are really responding to the
stores the client service and we're very
positive about the long-term Prospect of
Europe
we've only got about 30 seconds left
Ryan but um obviously you're about to go
into 35 pre-owned Rolex in quite a big
way you're not worried that's going to
cannibalize the sale of new Rolex
watches
uh not at all uh there's just not enough
you know Rolexes in the world we have
long waiting lists and a big disparity
between supply and demand but adding
more names to the waiting list than
we're taking off so the availability of
Rolex pre-owned will just be a great
thing for our clients who who want to
get product immediately it would like to
supply but there's just no way at all it
would be any cannibalization on a on new
Rolexes all right Brian always good to
talk to you thanks very much indeed for
joining me today
thank you
that's it from me I'm back at half past
four this afternoon with our afternoon
Edition see you then durian
foreign
[Music]